[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرد المستجدات
وفي العناوين
في تشكيله تحالف عسكري بين روسيا والصين
ويتهم حلف الناتو بتبني استراتيجيات
التوسع والتهديد
[تصفيق]
مع تفاقم الاحتياجات ضد خطه القضاء وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يحذر من تسرب
الانقسامات الداخليه الى الجيش
طرابلس تحتضن اجتماع عسكريا اليوم لتشكيل
قوه من الشرق والغرب تتولى تامين حقول
النفط في الجنوب
الاستقرار المالي العالمي في خطر مديره
صندوق النقد الدولي تحذر وتتوقع استمرار
تباطؤ النمو حتى 2024
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا قال رئيس الروسي الى
التعاون العسكري بين روسيا والصين هو
تعاون شفاف وواضح وليس تحالفا عسكريا
ودفاعيا ولا يشكل تحديدا لاي طرف واضاف
بوتين في تصريحات النحلتها وسائل اعلام
الروسيه اضاف ان الغرب هو من يبني المحاور
العسكريه ويعيد سيناريوهات الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وليس روسيا او الصين واضاف بوتين
ان المفهوم الاستراتيجي الجديد النيتو
يتمحور على التوسع وتهديد الاخر هذا
واتهمت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه القوات
الروسيه باستهداف مواقع اوكرانيه وبنا
تحتيه بواحد وسبعين هجوما بالمسيرات منذ
بدايه مارس الحالي واشارت الوزاره الى ان
استئناف روسيا الى الهجمات بالمسيرات بعد
توقف الدامه لاسبوعين يشير الى وجود
امدادات منتظمه لهذه الدرونز الى موسكو
كما قالت الوزاره ان روسيا والساعه طاقه
ضرباتها للمسيارات لتشتيت الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه وبموازات اله
يعتبر مجلس الامن الاوكراني تهديدات روسيا
بنشر اسلحه نوويه في بيلاروسيا بانها
بمثابه اتخاذ
رهينه للاسلحه النوويه وقال سكرتيرو مجلس
الامن الاوكراني اوريكسيدان
ستخاطر بزعزعه امنها اذا وافقت على نشر
اسلحه نوويه روسيه باراضها وقد اثار قرار
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين النقل اسلحه
النوويه تكتيكيه الى بيلاروسيا المجاوره
لكل من اوكرانيا وبولندا
اثار هذا القارو مخاوف الغرب من توسع رقعه
الحرب وذلك ردا على حوض بريطانيا لنقل
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم الى اوكرانيا
وتعليقا على الخطوه الروسيه قالت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه انه لا توجد مؤشرات على
ان روسيا تستعد لاستخدام اسلحه نوويه
وانها لم ترى اي سبب لتعديل وضع وتعديل
وضع واشنطن النووي الاستراتيجي
اذا بعد اعلان بوتين ارسال عشري مقاتلات
قادره على حمل اسلحه نوويه الى بيلاروسيا
تتبادر الى الاذهان اسئله حول حجم
الترسانه النوويه الروسيه ومن المتحكم بها
الاجابه مشاهدينا كشف عنها تقرير لوكاله
رايتز الذي اكد ان روسيا تمتلك اكبر مخزون
في العالم من رؤوس الحربيه النوويه
وبالارقام فان الرئيس الروسي يسيطر على
نحو سته الاف من هذه الرؤوس الحربيه
اعتبارا من العام المنصرم مقارنه مع نحو
5500 راس نووي يسيطر عليها نظيره الامريكي
لكن مشاهدينا هذا ليس كل شيء فبحسب
التقرير روسيا تدير 10 غواصات مسلحه نوويا
يمكنها ان تحمل 800 راس حربي كحد اقصى
ولديها ايضا ما بين 60 و70 قاذفه نوويه
وبهذه الارقام فان كل من موسكو او واشنطن
يمكنهما تدمير العالم عده مرات وبالعوده
الى شق من المتحكم بطرسانه النوويه يقول
التقرير ان بوتين يعتبر صانع القرار
النهائي حول استخدام هذه الاسلحه وفقا
للعقيده النوويه الروسيه حيث يحمل ما يعرف
بالحقيبه النوويه معه في كل الاوقات
ويمكنه عبرها تنشيط نظام اليد الميته كملد
اخير وذلك عبر اجهزه الكمبيوتر التي تقرر
ما يسمى بيوم القيامه
مشاهدينا بينضموا الينا الصحفي محمد
البابا اهلا بك محمد معنا في هذه النشره
كما تابعنا في نادونيس تشتكي من غارات
اوكرانيه مكثفه ربما بلغت اكثر من اربعه
عشره غاره خلال 24 ساعه ماذا نعرف اكثر
حول تفاصيل هذا الهجوم الاوكراني نعم
بالفعل يعني بعد ما خفت وتيره الهجوم
الروسي في مدينه باغود او كما يتداول في
وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه فشل روسيا في
عمليتها العسكريه في محور قام الجيش
الاوكراني بالامس قصف يعني اكثر من ست
مراكز عسكريه ومخازن اسلحه للجيش الروسي
وللانفصاليين ولمجموعات فارغنيرفين مقاطعه
خاصه من محور
وجهت المدفعيه الاوكرانيه ضربات لمواقع
داخل او عند اطراف مدينه دونسك وفي مناطق
اخرى ايضا القوات الروسيه ردت بقصف لداخل
مدينه باخمت القسطنطينيه حتى ضربات مدفعيه
من المدفعيه الروسيه مدينه ايضا بالامس
كان هناك يعني قصف بقذائف الهام وسقطت عند
اطراف مدينه ليمان حيث يقوم الجيش الروسي
باستعدادات ينفتح جبهه جديده في ذلك
المحور القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا يعني اكدت
بالامس ان
المبادره العسكريه او العمليات العسكريه
اصبحت يعني الى حد تحت السيطره داخل مدينه
باخمت وخفت وتيره الهجوم الروسي بشكل كبير
يعني بالامس كان هناك فقط 20 محاوله تقدم
للقوات الروسيه بينما كان يعني قبل اسبوع
كانت بالمعدل اليومي 70 الى 80 الى 90
محاوله اختراق يعني مراكز الجيش الاوكراني
طيب محمد كما تبعنا ايضا في سياق هذه
الاخبار حذرت بان روسيا قد بدات تستانف من
جديد ضرباتها بالمسيارات وهناك اشارات على
ان هناك امدادات مستمره لروسيا بهذه
المسيرات كيف تنظر اوكرانيا الى هذه
التقارير ما بدا استعدادتها لاي ضربات
روسيه خاصه بعد هذا الهجوم الكبير على
دونيسك
وايضا يعني بالامس كان هناك بيان
للاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه وسلاح
الجو الاوكراني واكد ان الان روسيا بدات
تستخدم منطقه بورج ومنطقه كورس انطلاق
لمسيرات ايرانيه وفي الفتره الماضيه يعني
كما يتداول حصلت يعني روسيا على عدد كبير
من المسيرات الايرانيه الانتحاريه التي
يعني كانت تستخدم وتستخدم اصبحت بشكل دوري
يعني قبل ثلاثه ايام كان هناك هجوم
بمثيرات وسببت 20 مسيره
استطعت الدفاعات الجويه
لذلك الان يعني بعدما خفت وتيره الضربات
الصاروخيه التي كانت يعني قبل حوالي ثلاثه
او اربعه اشهر كان الجيش الروسي اسبوعيا
يقصف المدن الاوكرانيه بصواريخ قريبك بعد
الجيش الاوكراني حصل على منظومات دفاعيه
لذلك عادت روسيا الاستراتيجيه الاستهداف
عبر المسيرات التي يعني هي ارخص كلفه
واكثر ضررا حيث انها يصعب التقاطها عبر
الرادارات ماذا يعرف ايضا عن حقيقه
الاوضاع الارض في باخ موت ومدى الجمود
الذي وصلت اليه المعارك هناك محمد يعني
الجيش الاوكراني كما يتداول انه يستعد
للبدء بهجوم مضاده بالامس كان هناك بيان
من وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه التي طالبت
الجميع بعدم نشر معلومات وتفاصيل عن ما
يحدث في مدينه لان الجيش الاوكراني اصبح
الان يمتلك المبادره يعني اصبحت القوات
الاوكرانيه هي التي تقوم بالهجوم على
مراكز القوات الروسيه في محيط باخمد بينما
كانت يعني قبل حوالي ثلاثه او اربعه ايام
كانت الصوره يعني معاكسه كانت جيش الروسي
هو الذي يقوم بالهجوم لذلك الوضع العمليات
لا يزال على حاله الجيش الاوكراني اصبح
مسيطرا ويمتلك المبادره بعد تراجع وبعدها
يعني نجحت استراتيجيه الجيش الاوكراني
باستهداف القوه الضاربه واستنزاف مجموعه
بشكل كبير يتداول يعني في وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه ويعني في جميع الوكالات انه
اكثر من 25 الف قتيل من مقاتله سقط نعم
فقط منذ بدايه العام الحالي حتى اليوم
شكرا لك من كنت معنا الصحفي محمد البابا
تحياتي محمد شكرا شكرا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن اجراء
اختبارات ناجحه على اسلحه سفينه بوريا
والعاصفه او العاصفه العسكريه التي طورت
لصالح اسطول بحر البلطيق في الجيش الروسي
نتابع
[موسيقى]
كشف مؤسس مجموعه فاغن الروسيه في مقطع
صوتي لمشروع تطبيق تيليجرام انه تم العفو
عن اكثر من خمسه الاف مجرم السابق بعد
انهاء عقودهم القتال في صفوف المجموعه في
اوكرانيا واضاف بريغوجين ان اقل من واحد
في المئه من المعفى عنهم بعد الخدمه في
فارغنر عادوا الى الجريمه مضيفا انها نسبه
اقل 10 مرات الى 20 مره من المؤشرات
القياسيه اكد محافظ بنك اوكرانيا المركزي
اندريبيشي لصحيفه
لتدبير تكاليف الحرب ضد روسيا واضاف ان
هذه السياسه تسببت في مخاطر كبيره على
الاستقرار المالي الكلي عندما اضطر البنك
العام الماضي الى طباعه مليارات من العمله
المحليه لسد العجز في الميزانيه مشيرا الى
ان سيئاتها طباعه النقود كانت علاجا سريعا
لكنها خطيره للغايه واضاف انه وقع صراع
مفتوح مع الحكومه بشان هذه المساله لكن تم
حلها بالكامل
نشاطنا مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
في ورطه القيمه الحاليه لتويتر انخفضت الى
نصف سعر شرايح
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد كشف تقرير
للقناه الثانيه عشر الاسرائيلي عن تزايد
الخلافات داخل حزب الديكور الذي يتزعمه
رئيس الوزراء
الجهاز القضائي واضافت القناه ان ثلاثه
اعضاء في البرلمان عن حزب الديكود طالبوا
بوقف الخطه فورا لينضموا الى وزير الدفاع
واشارت القناه الثانيه عشره ان اعضاء
الحزب الحاكم
للدخول في مفاوضات بشكل فوري مع المعارضه
حول خطه تعديل نظام القضاء وقد حذر
مسؤولون في الحكومه الاسرائيليه من تسرب
الانقسام الداخلي المتفاقم جراء
الاحتجاجات في البلاد الى مؤسسه الجيش
والدفاع وعلى اثر ذلك دعا وزير الدفاع الى
تجميد خطه اصلاح القضاء فورا قائلا ان
الخلافه المحتدمه بشانه يمثل خطرا مباشرا
على امن البلاد
ومع تفاقم الاحتياجات في تل ابيب تواجه
اسرائيل مشاهدينا واحده من اسوا ازماتها
السياسيه والقضائيه ومنذ رابع يناير
الماضي يسعى بنااهو لادخال تغييرات جذريه
على النظام القضائي تغييرات من شانها الحد
من سلطات المحاكمه المحكمه العليا في
اصدار احكام ضد سلطتين التشريعيه
والتنفيريه بينما تمنح النواب سلطه اكبر
في تعيين القضاه
ومن شان هذه المقترحات ايضا تغيير كل ذلك
بما يمنح الحكومه نفوذا اكبر بكثير لكن
لماذا كل تلك التغييرات لان العديد من
اليمينيين في اسرائيل يرون ان المحكمه
العليا تميل الى اليسار ونخبويه وتتدخل
بصوره كبيره ايضا في الشؤون السياسيه
وكذلك تقدم حقوق الاقليات على المصالح
الوطنيه في كثير من الاحيان لكن المتقدين
يحضرون من تداعيات كارثيه لمشروع القانون
مؤكدين ان التغييرات ستضعف المحكمه وتسلم
السلطه المطلقه للحكومه ما يعرض الحريات
المدنيه الخطر مع اثار كارثيه على
الاقتصاد والعلاقات مع حلفاء الغربيين
بحسب رويترز
اليوم الثاني عشر من هذه الاحتياجات
المستمره التي تجتاح مدن اسرائيليه عده
كيف كانت تقييم لهذه الاحتجاجات هل كانت
مرضيه بنسبه للمعارضه وما الذي يتوقع ايضا
في مقوي الايام
اهلا بك احمد صحيح يعني تشهد اسرائيل ازمه
هي الكبرى منذ سنوات او حتى منذ نشاتها
نتحدث عن احتجاجات كبيره اكثر من 200
وخمسين الف متظاهر تواجدوا ليله امس في تل
ابيب وعشرات المواقع ضد التعديلات
القضائيه وايضا ضد حكومه نتنياهو التي
تريد السيطره على
الحكومه وتريد ايضا اضعاف المحكمه العليا
نتحدث ايضا عن وزير الدفاع وهو ايضا عضو
بارز في في حزب الكود والذي يتراسه
باليمين نتنياهو ويعتبر ايضا حزب يميني
ولكن وزير الدفاع ليله امس خرج وصرح بشكل
علني لاول مره انه ضد هذه التعديلات
القضائيه وينصح بنيامين نتنياهو بتاجيل
هذه التعديلات حتى بعد اعلان استقلال
اسرائيل اي بعد شهر من اليوم اي نتحدث
ايضا عن تخوفات من رؤ كبار ووزراء وايضا
من وزير الدفاع نفسه حيث صرح بان فعليا
هذه التعديلات ستؤدي الى كارثه في اسرائيل
وتؤدي ايضا الى انقسامات نشهدها ايضا في
الجيش وداخل المؤسسه الامنيه وداخل
المؤسسه العسكريه هناك اكثر ايضا ازدياد
في اعداد الجنود الاحتياط الذين يرفضون
الخدمه العسكريه ايضا عناصر من المخابرات
الاسرائيليه هددوا بانهم سوف يقومون
بالغاء خدمتهم والغائ عقودهم الموقعه مع
المخابرات الاسرائيليه اذا الحكومه مضت
قدما في هذه التعديلات القضائيه اي
اسرائيل حاليا تشهد ازمه داخل مؤسساتها
العسكريه وداخل مؤسساتها الامنيه هناك
ايضا يعني في الصحف الاسرائيليه تحذير من
نشوب انقلاب عسكري ربما يعني شاهدنا ايضا
في الايام الماضيه كان في الخطاب الصحف
كان الخطاب يوجد فيه حرب اهليه ولكن الان
الخطاب يتحول الى انقلاب عسكري وهو الاخضر
ايضا يعني بعض من جنون
ايضا من انزلاق الامور نحو اوضاع الاسواق
بعد تحول هذه الاحتياجات الى شارع مقابل
شارع سننتمي بهذا القدر لضيق الوقت شكرا
لك العربيه لا نقول
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس اجتماعا عسكريا
بين اعضاء اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه
الليبيه خمسه زائد خمسه ورئيس الاركان
العامه باشراف المبعوثيلي ومن المنتظر
الاجتماع عن تشكيل قوه عسكريه مشتركه من
ثلاث كتائب عسكريه من شرق ليبيا وغربها
وجنوبها لتامين الحقول النفطيه في الجنوب
الليبي وياتي اللقاء اثاره اجتماعي امري
تمهيدي عقد السبت في اطار الجهود الدوليه
الاقليميه لاخراج ليبيا من مازقها السياسي
من العاصمه الليبيه مشاهدينا طرابلس ينضم
الينا مراسله العربيه منير الاشهب اهلا بك
منير ومنير ما هي ابرد التحديات التي
تواجه تشكيل هذه القوه المشتركه بين قوات
من الشرق وغرب ليبيا ايضا
في المنطقه الشرقيه يبقى امل توحيد يعني
مثل هذه المؤسسات العسكريه يبقى امر
توحيدها في يد يعني السلطه الليبيه خصلتنا
ان هذا ليس هو اللقاء الاول الذي يجمع هذه
اللجنه هنا في طرابلس كان حدث ذلك في
الماضي تسير يعني هذه العمليات نفقه طويله
الامد
حيث انها تمتد هذه المفاوضات منذ فتره
طويله بين الشرق والغرب ولجنه خمسه زائد
خمسه التي نجحت يوقف يعني في تثبيت وقف
اطلاق النار وايضا في عديد من الملفات
ايضا الامر الذي لا يزال يتعلق هو اخراج
المرتزقه والمقاتلين الى الجانب التي تشرف
عليهم المفترض ان تشرف عليه
اليوم في طرابلس تعتذر منك هذا ما سمح به
الوقت وكنت معنا من العاصمه الليبيه
طرابلس مراسل العربيه منير الاشعري شكرا
منير
مشاهدينا تنطلق اليوم في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري اخر ملفات المرحله النهائيه من
العمليه السياسيه الجاريه في بلاد منذ
توقيع الاتفاق الاطار وستضمن توصيات
الارشاف الاتفاق السياسي النهائي الذي
ينتظر ان يسلم اليوم من قبل لجنه مشتركه
من العسكريين والمدنيين وتناقش ورشه دمج
قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش وفق جدول زمني
يتفق عليه ودمج الفصائل المسلحه وفقا
للبند المنصوص عليه في اتفاق جبل السلام
الورشه مشاهدينا يتوقع ان تخرج بخريطه
طريق تساعد في ترتيبات الاصلاح في
القطاعات الامنيه والنظاميه وهي الجيش
والدعم السريع والشرطه والامن
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
وسط توتر مع الصين جزيره تايوان تتعرض
لانتكاسه جديده وتفقد اعتراف هندوراس بها
[موسيقى]
قتل ينفي تشكيله تحالف عسكري بين روسيا
والصين
مع تفاقم الاحتياجات خطه القضاء وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يحذر من تسرب
الانقسامات الداخليه الى الجيش
طرابلس تحتضن اجتماعا عسكريا اليوم لتشكيل
قوه من الشرق والغرب تتولى تامين حقول
النفط في الجنوب
الاستقرار المالي العالمي في خطر مديره
صندوق النقد الدولي تحذر وتتوقع استمرار
تباطؤ النبوي حتى 2024
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد قالت وكاله
انباء الصين الجديده ان الصين
وذلك بعد قطع الاخيره علاقاتها
الدبلوماسيه مع تايوان واشارت الوكاله ان
الصين وهندوراس اتفقتها على تطوير علاقات
على اسس بل على اساس مبادئ احترام
المتبادل للسياده والسلام الاقليميه
بدورها وصفت وزهره الخارج الامريكيه قرار
هندوراس قطع العلاقات مع تايوان كانه قرار
سيادي مشيره الى اهميه الانتباه الى
الوعود التي غالبا ما تقدمها الصين في
مقابل اعتراف دبلوماسي بانها لا تفي بها
في نهايه المطاف فيما اعتبر وزير خارج
التايواني ان رئيس الهندوراس زيومارا
كاسترو تساورها اوهام بشان وعود الصين لها
بتقديم مساعدات اقتصاديه
اكدت الشرطه الالمانيه سقوط قتيلين بعد
اطلاق نار وقع في مدينه هامبورج واضافت
انها فتحت تحقيقا واحجمت الشرطه عن ذكر اي
تفاصيل تتعلق بمطلق النار كما رجحت مراسله
العربيه بان الحادثه ليس مرتبطا بعمليه
ارهابيه
تواصل السلطات الامريكيه عمليات البحث
والانقاذ على اثر الاعصار القوي الذي
شهدته ولايه حيث لقي ما لا يقل عن 26 شخصا
مصرعهم كما يعتقد بل يعتقد ان الكثيرين
لازالوا عالقين تحت حطام المنازل التي
دمرها الاعصار فيما اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن حاله الطوارئ في ولايه
[موسيقى]
عرض رجل الاعمال الامريكي الى ماسك على
موظفي تويتر جوائز الاسهم بناء على قيمه
اجماليه للشركه تبلغ نحو 20 مليار دولار
اي اقل من نصف سعر البالغ 44 مليارا الذي
اشتراها مقابله حسب ما افاد موقع نقلا عن
مصادر مطلعه المراسلات الداخليه لشركه
الموقع اعتبر ذلك بانه اعتراف مباشر لمدى
انخفاض قيمه منصه تويتر منذ ثواني ماسك
ادارتها ولم يعلق ماسك بعد على هذه
المعلومات
قالت مديره صندوق النقد الدولي كريستالينا
ان المخاطر التي تحدق بالاستقرار المالي
قد تزايد تداعيه الى مواصله توخي الحذر
رغم تحركات الاقتصادات المتقدمه لتهدئه
ان العام الحالي سيكون مليئا بالتحديات مع
تباطؤ النمو العالمي الى اقل من ثلاثه في
المئه
والحرب في اوكرانيا وتجديد السياسه
النقديه مشيره الى انه حتى مع وجود رؤيه
مستقبليه افضل لعام 2024 سيظل النمو
العالمي اقل بكثير من متوسط التاريخي
البالغ ثلاثه في المئه فاصله ثمانيه
مشاهدينا من باريس ينضموا الينا الباحث في
العلوم الماليه والاقتصاديه الدكتور حسن
عبيد اهلا بك دكتور حسن معنا في هذه
النشره بدايه ما مدى خطوره الوضع حول
الاستقرار المالي العالمي الذي حضرت منه
مديره الصندوق النقد الدولي وما ابرز هذه
المخاطر ايضا
لقد حصلت مدينه صندوق النقل في اكثر من
المناسبه يعني حتى في كل تقرير لصندوق
النقد كان تحذر بان العام 2023 سيكون
سيكون يعني عليه ضغوطات كبيره والعام 2024
سيكون له سيكون هناك بعض التحسن ولكن لن
يصل الى المستوى العالمي كما ذكرت مديره
صندوق اهم المقاطر هي استمرار الحرب فاذا
ما استمرت الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه فهذا
خطر كبير على الاقتصاد العالمي الخطر
الثاني الذي هو نتيجه الحرب والنتيجه
كورونا هو
تدهور الاسواق الماليه او اذا ما كنت
تداوي يعني السوق وضع الاسواق الماليه على
الرغم من السيطره على المصالح مصر
ولكن يبقى هناك خوف عند المستثمر مما يحصل
في الاسواق الماليه وفي المصارف بالتحديد
فهناك وهذا هو كان سؤال يعني هل يشمل ذلك
المخاطر ما حدث في
والبنك الامريكي الاخر يحطون اسم هذه
اللحظه السيليكون فالي نعم تفضل
نتائج الحرب الاوكرانيه يبقى ان هناك
المساق المركزيه تسيطر وتحاول السيطره على
هذه على هذه
العوارض ولكن الى متى يمكن ان تسيطر خاصه
اذا ما نظرنا الى صندوق الى الفيدرالي
الامريكي على الرغم من خطوره رفع سعر
الفائده ولكنه رفع سعر الفائده الى 25
نقطه المص المركزي الاوروبي اعتقد سيذهب
بنفس المنوال لانه بحاجه
يعني
ردم قوه التضخم من ناحيه وبحاجه لمساعده
المصارف التي تت
عثر فهو بحاجه للاموال لذلك يبحث على
الفائده الى متى الحل هو
تس
لل الى متى سيستمر هذا الوضع
كلما يستمر الوضع على ما هو عليه واذا ما
وجد وجد حل للجلوس على طاوله واحده فربما
يعني تنعدم امكانيه التدهور الاقتصادي طيب
دكتور حسن احنا ما نتحدث عن تباطؤ النمو
العالمي هل نعني التراجع عن نسبه ثلاثه في
المئه فاصله ثمانيه اما ان ذلك يحمل قدره
من المبالغه في تقديرك لا ليس مبالغا
فالتراجع عن النسبه 3.8 هو امر يعني متوقع
جدا وخاصه هنا ازيد امر مهم جدا على
الخارطه الجيو السياسيه في العالم عندما
نجد التقارب الروسي السعودي الايراني
الصيني في مقابل
المحور الاخر المحور الغربي الامريكي فهذا
امر لا بد من مراقبته بدقه
وربما الانتظار
باصدار عمله عمله
قريبا وهذه اصدار العمله التي تضاهي
الدولار ربما تكون التي تقصد ظهر البعير
الاقتصادي وتؤدي الى انقسام
المحاور الاقتصاديه الى جزئين الغربي
والصيني الروسي وحلفائهم من ناحيه اخرى
نعم
الباحث في العلوم الماليه والاقتصاديه
دكتور حسن عبيد شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حسن
شكرا
مشاهدينا نتابع جانبا من ورشه الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري التي بدات في الخرطوم
ونتوقع بعد قليل كلمه لرئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
وستضمن الورشه توصيات في الاتفاق النهائي
الذي ينتظر ان يسلم اليوم من قبل لجنه
مشتركه من العسكريين والمدنيين اذا نتابع
هذه الصور انطلاق ورشه الاصلاح الامري
والعسكري في الخرطوم ونحن الان بانتظار
كلمه رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان ماذا اذا الكلمات تتوالى
من بعض المسؤولين المشاركين في
العمليه العسكريه او العمليه السياسيه
عفوا في السودان
ما بدا كهوايات وشغف تحول الى مصدر دخل
لفتيات وسيدات كثيرات في مصر اعداد كبيره
من النسوه يقمن بصناعه منتجات متعدده منها
منتجات رمضانيه والنزول بها في معرض تنظم
خصيصا في النوادي والاماكن العامه لغرض
التسويق تنظيم المعارض بكثره عدم مره اخرى
بكامل قوته بعد توقف بسبب كورونا فهل تاثر
البيع بالازمه الاقتصاديه نتابع
[موسيقى]
بينما ينشغل الغالبيه في تامين احتياجاتهم
الغذائيه في رمضان من خلال الاسواق
والشوادر والمعارض هناك فئه من السيدات
ينتظرن مثل هذه المواسم فهم يصنعن عددا
كبيرا من المنتجات المختلفه بايديهم
ويستهدفن شهر رمضان كاحد مواسم الرواج
احنا ابتديناها كفيسبوك اسمه للستات اللي
عندها مشاريع صغيره
وبيدوروا على طريقه يسوقوا بها منتجاتهم
دي فاحنا عملنا جروب الستات بتخش وبتدخل
صحابها عشان زي ما قلت لك المنتجات عندنا
لها طبيعه كاستمايز كده والناس بتعمل
حاجات بقيتها فبتعملها ليها علاقه بمثلا
مناسبات عامه دائما السيزون الحلو بالنسبه
لنا هو الشوبنج سيزون العالي اللي هو
كريسماس رمضان
قبل الصيف على طول السيزنس دي بتبقى
عايزين يشتروا حاجات وربما تراجع وجوده
مثل هذه المعارض خلال فتره الكورونا
ولكنها عادت بقوه خلال العام الماضي والان
تشهد رواجا لدى فئات بعينها قادره على
شراء في ظل الظروف الصعبه الكورونا يعني
كانت هي اكبر فلوس لنا يعني قعدتنا في
البيت فالناس بتشتري اون لاين فالحمد لله
الدنيا كانت ماشيه كويس قوي لما ابتدينا
بقى ننزل للناس تاني بعد ما المعارض رجعت
طبعا فرق جدا برضو الحمد لله
الناس بقت بتشوف الحاجه على الطبيعه
روح المعرض نفسه هتشتري مني هتشتري من
غيري كنا بننزل قبل كده بحاجات ملونه بس
لقيناه الناس حابه كلمه رمضان كريم على
الحاجه يعني في حاجات ثانيه باعت اقل لما
الناس ابتعدت تحس ان احنا مش هنخرج يبقى
مش هنشتري لبس
وجوليري واكسسوريز وكده بس الدنيا تظبط
بقى ان كل الحمد لله خلاص ابتدا ان هو
الناس ترجع وتبقى عايز تشتري حاجات مختلفه
وكده لا تكاد تمر عطله نهايه اسبوع خلال
شهر مارس الا وبها عدد من المعارض
والبازارات التي تخاطب فئات او فرحات في
الدخل
في شرق وغرب العاصمه حيث فرص اصطياد
منتجات مميزه لشهر رمضان قائمه وبشكل افضل
من الشراء عبر الانترنت من وجهه نظر
الكثيرين تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
تحمل العديد من المسلسلات في موسم رمضان
الحالي اسماء شخصياتها الموجوده فيها
بالعمل الدرامي سواء بشكل مباشر او غير
مباشر امر يراه النقاده وسيله من قبل
المنتجين لتحقيق جذب جماهيري لاعمالهم
المزيد من الاراء عن الموضوع في فقره
الكواليس من اعداد ايهم القاسم وتقديم سهى
الوعل
[موسيقى]
ده ابني اللي ما خلفتهوش
مش عايزه تروح من دماغي ابدا
[موسيقى]
جعفر مش بالعالم بتاعي
ولا انا من العالم بتاعي خالص
مرحبا تحمل العديد من الاعمال في رمضان
اسماء ابطالها بمعنى يعني ان المسلسل ياتي
باسم ابرز بطل فيه مثلا مسلسل جعفر اللي
عنده بطوله محمد رمضان مسلسل رشيد بطوله
محمد ممدوح مسلسل الكبير بطوله احمد مكي
ومسلسل جميله بطوله ريهام حجاج هتدفع
وانا لما بحط في دماغي
شفت المصيبه اللي احنا فيها انا ابتديت
مشوار وهكمله
اعمال اخرى باسماء شخصيات ابطالها لكن
بشكل غير مباشر على سبيل المثال هناك
مسلسل رمضان كريم حيث يلعب سيد رجب شخصيات
رمضان ومسلسل يتسليمه حيث تلعب دنيا سمير
غانم شخصيه سليمه ومسلسل عمله نادره حيث
تلعب نيللي كريم شخصيه نادره ومسلسل وعود
تخيه حيث تلعب حنان مطاوع شخصيه
وهو امر يجد النقاد اذكى والطف وقعا على
المشاهد ساعات كتير بيبقى اسم الفيلم او
اسم المسلسل على اسم بطله او على اسم
الشخصيه الرئيسيه فيه ازاي الشخصيه يتطور
وبتروح فين في ذكاء في ده والساعات كتير
بيبقى استسهال بس ده مش الحاله العامه
الحاله العامه بتبقى هي ان انا ببني شخصيه
مهمه قوي في الدراما فعشان كده عايز اسمي
الفيلم باسمها ماذا عن الجمهور وهل يرى
الامر عاديا ام يفضل ان تحمل هذه الاعمال
اسماء اكثر ابتكارا ولماذا المفروض الاسم
المسلسل يكون على السيناريو بتاع المسلسل
او الاحداث عامة لو اسم الشخص في المسلسل
فهو مش هيشد حد
لك واسمي مثلا مثير للفضول في المسلسل
اكيد هيسير في دول الناس اكتر بكثير من
اسم الشخص يعني
يكون اكثر غمودا اكثر
بالنسبه لي الاسم مش هيفرق طبعا المحتوى
هيعجبني وجذب الناس المحتوى اهم حاجه
المحتوى
[موسيقى]
عمر
يا عمر يا عمر
يا عمر عمر
[موسيقى]
بابرز العناوين
ينفي تشكيله تحالف عسكري بين روسيا والصين
ويتهم حلف الناتو بتبني استراتيجيات
التوسع والتهديد
مع تفاقم الاحتجاجات ضد خطه القضاء وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يحذر من تسرب
الانقسامات الداخليه الى الجيش
طرابلس تحتضن اجتماعا عسكريا اليوم لتشكيل
قوه من الشرق والغرب تتولى تامين حقول
النفط في الجنوب
الاستقرار المالي العالمي في خطر مديره
صندوق النقد الدولي تحذر وتتوقع استمرار
تباطؤ النمو حتى 2024
اخباريه مشاهدينا كونوا بعافيه